отут стоїть прапор Європейського Союзу
ми говоримо Ми хочемо в Європу Покажіть
мені будь ласка одну країну
Європейського Союзу де голова
антимонопольного комітету де голова
рахункової палати є родичкою родини
президента одну я прошу показати мені
одну країну члена Євросоюзу чи Сполучені
Штати Америки чи Канада Де таке бачили А
в Україні Будь ласка пані піщанська яку
не вдалося проштовхнути передноворічне
засідання тепер проштовхують
післяноворічне засідання Ну ви розумієте
не треба ображатися казати Ну як так
можна робити де ж кінець епохи кумавства
де розумієте чому вас не призначають Ну
тому що ви не сусіди президента не друзі
не родичі Ваша сестра не є власницею
фірми на яка оформлена Віла родини
зеленських